after more than a month-long trial after
years of Investigations New York
prosecutors have convicted two
trump-owned entities of tax crimes and
if you listen to The Establishment media
you understand that that means
that they've got him now
the walls are closing in Donald Trump is
done
where have I heard that before
Donald Trump's done he's done there's no
question about that he's done breaking
news a bombshell today is a turning
point today was historically bad for
president Trump today was a turning
point a turning point we're at a turning
point here the beginning of the end for
the Trump presidency the beginning of
the end and breaking news we have
another bombshell Mike Pence might have
to assume the office of the presidency
the call for impeachment Rumblings of
the word impeachment breaking news
another bombshell out of the White House
I believe this is the beginning of the
end I do too it's really the beginning
of the end the beginning of the end he
may be feeling the walls closing in on
him all the walls closing in on him the
walls closing in on him breaking news a
new bombshell one astrologer says this
means the beginning of the end for
president Donald Trump the beginning of
the end of the Trump presidency
Trump is going to resign is this the
Tipping Point I know we've said it over
and over you think this is a Tipping
Point and over and over this is a
Tipping Point an over and over over
breaking news president Trump off the
rails it was the beginning of the end
today
okay so maybe the libs have cried wolf
before but surely they've got him this
time I mean I have got the New York
Times report on this case right here and
right here in the report it is clear
that
Donald Trump has not been convicted of
any crime
actually apparently he wasn't even
charged with any crime but the tax fraud
does come with a maximum penalty of
uh
1.62 million dollars which even the
times describes as quote a rounding
error for Mr Trump
1.62 million dollars that is
significantly less than the amount of
taxpayer money Democrats have wasted
investigating and Prosecuting this case
but still according to the times this
verdict represents a highly public
Reckoning for the Trump organization
forever branding it as a felonious
Enterprise now perhaps best known for
its conviction
so this verdict doesn't hurt Donald
Trump legally or financially or
politically but the New York Times is
confident that it will change people's
opinions about the most famous and
polarizing man on Earth
the reputation of the man the Liberals
have spent years smearing as an
incontinent lecherous incestuous
traitorous insurrectionist will never be
able to survive a minor tax fine
they've got him now
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show I hope we can
make it through the whole show there is
a shot we will have the technical
difficulty of of the walls closing in in
which case the cameras in the desk would
be smushed but we're going to try to
avoid it I think we're going to probably
make it just fine my favorite comment
yesterday is from jodman kuzland who
says Michael keeps talking about how his
books would be great gift ideas yet
every time I check the DW shop they're
sold out
I've become one of those desperate
people constantly checking stock do I
have to head down to DW headquarters and
camp out for days until my consumer
needs are met don't threaten me with a
good time Michael Well you certainly can
do that I don't want to discourage you
from doing that but also if the DW shop
is sold out which apparently they are
and probably will be until Christmas you
can get speechless controlling words
controlling Minds my number one National
best-selling book with words in it and
you can get reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide which is
my number one Amazon best-selling book
without words in it endorsed by
President Trump you can get both of them
anywhere you can get them on Amazon
Barnes and Noble Indie books
your local Bookshop
wherever fine books are sold so head on
to fdw has run out
you can find it elsewhere okay you can
do it you can you can actually run down
to the store especially if you're in
good shape because of your Echelon right
now text Knowles to 81 81.81 I have been
working too hard this year okay to bring
you this show as a result
I'll say it I've not been working out
enough all right I want to get in shape
I want to be fit and hot and young and
sexy and I don't have time to go to the
gym which is why I love Echelon Fitness
Echelon brings the gym home to me
Echelon Fitness is the affordable way to
get workout equipment a workout
community and an instructor's motivation
right in the comfort and privacy of your
own home Echelon fitness's Connected app
provides thousands of Live And on-demand
classes with great music to keep you
moving you can work at any time day or
night their full range of affordable
workout equipment includes stationary
bikes that's what I have their bike is
phenomenal smart rowers Sleek Fitness
screens and an auto folding treadmill
these are all connected to the echelon
fitness app for The Full Experience
Around the Clock classes including full
body workout programs will keep you
coming back one membership covers a
family of five for a limited time
our audience can get a free bike or
rowing machine with a 24-month
membership this is an amazing deal a
free bike or rowing machine to get your
free bike or rower text Knowles kwles to
81 8181 that is Knolls to 81 8181 to
claim your free bike or rowing machine
text Knowles to 81 8181 message and data
rates may apply C term for details in
other news
forgetting for a second the 2024
presidential race in either news
Georgia voted last night Rafael Warnock
has defeated Herschel Walker in the race
I'm not totally surprised by this
outcome and I'm not totally surprised
that they called the race either
yesterday and the day before the
establishment media were Preparing
People to say this is going to be a
close race and uh therefore we're not
going to know the results very likely on
Election night it might take days or
weeks to count the ballots but and it
was a very close race but
the only reason that a close race would
result in it taking days and weeks to
count the ballots is if Herschel had
been leading but because Raphael Warnock
was leading they were willing to call
the race and the remaining votes that
are yet to be counted seem like they'll
break for Warnock uh you can say
that this is very unfair to Republicans
because of the widespread mail and
ballots because of the early voting
because of all the stupid voter laws
that heavily favored Democrats that is
certainly true that was kind of baked in
though from the beginning we knew that
that was the case uh Republicans in
Georgia should have done more to tighten
up the election laws if that was a real
number one concern the RNC should have
done more to fight these issues they did
not I'm not terribly surprised that
Herschel lost Herschel was not the
strongest candidate in the primary I
wasn't convinced that he was the
strongest candidate a lot of people were
were taken with the fact that he is a
sports legend and they thought that
people would just go down to The Ballot
Box because of that I I was never
totally convinced on that I actually
think that when people look at
candidates that way and they say well
the candidates just super duper famous
so therefore all those dumb Lemmings who
don't know anything about politics
they'll go pull the lever for them I
don't think that is respectful to the
voters that was I think the calculus for
the push to make Dr Oz the nominee in
Pennsylvania even though I thought Dr Oz
was a very weak Republican candidate and
so I'm not terribly surprised it's also
a little silver lining not terribly
consequential
the Democrats already had control of the
Senate
so it's not as though had Herschel
Walker won Republicans would have
control of the Senate it would have been
a better situation for Republicans would
have been easier to pry one Democrat
vote away than to now try to provide two
Democrat votes away but not not terribly
unexpected not terribly consequential uh
sad nonetheless and two takeaways here
are Republicans need to
focus on issues that matter probably a
little bit more than than just voter ID
when it comes to picking candidates and
we got to fix the the voter laws guys
and we got to get rid of early voting
and we've got to get rid of the
widespread mail-ins and we've got to
tighten up voter Integrity Democrats are
going to keep winning as long as that as
that is on the table
speaking of Elections and speaking of
predictions of mine that have come
correct I really should have brought my
Nostradamus hat over here because I'm I
offhandedly made a prediction at the end
of the show yesterday I said there's
this one last story I want to get to
it's the time man of the year and there
were all of these candidates many of
whom are just absolute Idols of the left
and I said but we all know that uh it's
going to be zelenski almost certainly
it's going to be zelenski and it's not
going to be Elon Musk it's not going to
be this guy it's not going to be that
guy uh it'll it'll be the president of
Ukraine and it is
just my producer just told me in my ear
it is in fact uh Vladimir zolenski time
man of the year and he didn't even
plunge us into World War III to win it
you know
although he sort of fried you have to
say come on West Go bomb Moscow come on
let's Elevate this thing into a global
war between nuclear superpowers that's a
good idea but in any case he is he is
the man of the year so
uh tough news for Herschel Walker
congratulations to president zielinski
let's have some better luck next time
with the election speaking of
potentially rigged elections much more
clearly rigged elections in this case
there was a new
bombshell with regard to the Twitter
files story this was the story that Elon
Musk chose the journalist Matt taibi to
release about how Twitter colluded with
the Democrats to censor the hunter Biden
laptop story to rig the 2020 election
for Joe Biden
a major deal it's not just that they
suppressed a news story they
wouldn't let you post the news story in
public they wouldn't let you privately
message the news story that was a a
tactic that had previously been reserved
for child pornography online then they
added this story that was damaging to
Joe Biden as well and then after the
election
12 of respondents to a survey right
after the election said that they would
not have voted for Joe Biden had they
known about the laptop story
take it with a grain of salt but it
shows you it was pretty significant
obviously the Democrats thought it was
significant that's the way they went to
such extraordinary lives to suppress it
so one thing that was really interesting
about the Twitter file story is that
though it showed Twitter employees
giving advantages to the DNC taking
taking marching orders from Democrats
you didn't see any evidence of
government collusion
and you will recall
when I was talking about that story it
may have been yesterday or two days ago
I said there's more to come this isn't
the end of the story this is Elon Musk
saying here's the first part of the
story but we are going to get more and I
assume that what comes out now will be
an answer to this left-wing rejoinder
which is well there was no evidence of
government collusion wasn't the FBI
wasn't the doj get over Republicans well
now it turns out
do you know who the lawyer in charge of
vetting the Twitter files releases from
Twitter was
a guy named James Baker
who is a lawyer for the FBI
and he was a lawyer for the FBI that was
very very controversial and involved in
all sorts of shady stuff
and the journalists Barry Weiss is
apparently the journalist working on the
next release of the Twitter file story
she finds out she says wait hold on who
are we waiting on the vetting for who
are we waiting on oh it's his lawyer
who's the lawyer's name Baker what's the
lawyer's first name James Baker James
Baker she said her jaw dropped the floor
do you think that might have something
to do
with the fact that the FBI was not
mentioned in the Twitter files release
that the guy whose job it was to scrub
the Twitter files was a lawyer for the
FBI which Elon Musk did not know about
until yesterday when he fired the guy
good that elon's fired him
but you just it's just an amazing
state that we're in right now
which is that the Democrats pull
shenanigans but then so much of their
corruption is not even about whatever
original action they're trying to take
so much of their corruption is about
making sure that the corruption they
already engaged in never comes out so
much of the FBI and doj corruption in
2016 was about destroying the Trump
campaign so that it never came out that
they spied on the Trump campaign in the
first place did the bidding of the
Democrats so much of this Twitter
corruption is yes we know they censored
the story but now you have the this
apparent cover-up to make sure that it
never comes out that the FBI was
involved as well when we know that the
FBI pressured Facebook to Hunter to
censor the hunter Biden laptop story so
does anybody really believe there was no
connection here no communication between
the FBI and Twitter for goodness sakes
the lawyer vetting it was a lawyer for
the FBI give me a break and give me the
second round of those Twitter files
cannot wait to read it I'm going to wake
up early I'm gonna get myself a nice cup
of Black Rifle coffee and then I'm going
to read those files right now head on
over to Black riflecoffee.com use promo
code Knowles Black Rifle coffee company
is helping you knock out your Christmas
shopping with a ton of phenomenal new
products this year shop the best Brewing
gear thermoses mugs and Apparel Design
for folks who love country and coffee
Black Rifle source is the most exotic
roasts from around the globe all coffee
is roasted here in the U.S by
veteran-led teams of coffee experts
stuff your Christmas stockings with the
latest roasts from America's coffee for
10 off with my code Knowles kwles better
yet sign your Secret Santa up for a
coffee Club subscription imagine the joy
of a pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roasts when you need the most
it is the gift that keeps on giving
Black Rifle Coffee Company veteran
founded and operated they take pride in
serving coffee and culture to people who
love America every purchase you make
with Black Rifle helps support veteran
and first responder causes go to black
riflecoffee.com
use promo code nulls for 10 off coffee
Coffee Gear apparel or when you sign up
for a new coffee Club subscription
that's black riflecoffee.com with promo
code Knowles for 10 off Black Rifle
coffee supporting veterans and America's
coffee
speaking of free speech we talked
yesterday about this case 303 creative
versus Ennis which is a case about
whether or not the state of Colorado
can force a wedding website designer to
engage in speech that violates her
religious views
whether the state of Colorado can force
a wedding website designer
to participate in a quote unquote gay
marriage so not marriage as it was
understood for all of human history
until 2015.
but this new definition of marriage
which takes away the intrinsic nature of
marriage
which violates the religious beliefs of
Christians Jews Muslims
and many other people who have less
well-defined religions the White House
has now weighed in on this question and
the White House answer is
yes we recognize the uh the right to
free speech and we support ensuring that
no one is discriminated against or
refused services because of who they
love and who they are and so as you know
we've been very clear about that the
administration believes that every
person no matter their sex race religion
or who they love should have the equal
access to society including access to
products and services on the same terms
as other members of public uh look
Department of Justice said in its brief
that for decades non-discrimination
public accommodations laws have
coexisted with the First Amendment
courts have recognized that we can
recognize that we can require businesses
open to public to service people
regardless of their backgrounds even
when that means businesses must
incidentally
engage in speech which they are which
they disagree upon so this is no reason
to up end this balance right now
so green Jean-Pierre is saying we
support free speech and you should have
the right to say what you want to say
and not say what you don't want to say
but then very quickly she says also the
government has the right to coerce you
into saying speech that you don't want
to say and that you don't believe in and
that violates your religious views and
she's blurring the lines here she's
saying because the law in the middle of
the 20th century
came in and forced private businesses to
serve people that they didn't want to
serve so get rid of this idea of freedom
of Association and says that to solve
the scourges of racism and all these
historic problems in the U.S we're going
to force you to engage in associations
that maybe you don't want to because of
that
we we can now force you to engage in
speech that you don't believe in these
are totally separate issues
but she's trying to blur the lines
because Karine Jean-Pierre wants it to
seem as though forcing This Woman This
Christian woman to participate in a
quote-unquote gay marriage is the same
thing as forcing the racist
Innkeeper or the racist restaurant owner
to serve Black customers when they are
completely separate issues both very
interesting questions but absolutely
completely separate and she gives it
away when at the end she says and
sometimes when when we're forcing you to
serve customers that you have some awful
terrible prejudice against incidentally
that will involve compelling speech from
you
well this isn't incidental when we're
talking about the wedding website
creator yes it's true if if a restaurant
owner has to serve a customer that the
restaurant owner doesn't like that will
incidentally compel certain speech like
how do you like your eggs
do you want milk in your coffee or not
sure but that's very different from a
person whose job it is to write a person
whose job it is to create
text and rhetoric and oratory to go in
and use their faculties of creativity
and reason to advocate for something
that they oppose
when we're talking about someone
creating a wedding website and writing
up all the content for that website it's
much more akin to a speechwriter than it
is to a restaurant owner and nobody
would seriously argue that a
speechwriter a republican speechwriter
is required to write a speech for a
Democrat candidate well these days
probably the White House would argue
that so I'll flip it no one seriously
argues that a Democrat speechwriter has
to be forced to take on a republican
client
and write all sorts of things that the
Democrat disagrees with that no one no
one seriously argues that but the White
House is is just saying look we're going
to force our our will on you we are
going to cram this radical and absurd
definition of marriage down everybody's
throat even if you're Christian Jewish
Muslim whatever we don't care your
religious views mean nothing to us the
views on the ordinary views on marriage
of everybody for all of human history
until five minutes ago means nothing to
us you will comply you will affirm the
Absurd thing that we're claiming two
plus two equals five and you will love
big brother you will say it and and so
the the analogy they're making
is silly the comparison to say well look
if you're a restaurant or you have to
serve everybody the the 303 creative
lady the wedding website lady is saying
I will serve anybody I I'm not turning
away any customers but I'm only offering
this one kind of service
a service for marriage as it is
traditionally understood
so I'm not I'm not I'm also not making
websites for baseball teams you know I'm
not making websites for PR agencies I'm
making websites for weddings I
understand weddings to be this thing and
I'm not going to violate my religious
views
any customer can come to me the gayest
guy in the world Liberace himself can
walk up to me say I'm going to get
married make me a wedding website she
will do that as long as he's getting
married to a woman which is intrinsic to
the very nature of marriage but Korean
jump here and the libs want to and and
the Liberals on the Supreme Court by the
way
one to blur this and say no no this is
just like the racist restaurant owners
and if you have a business you cannot
turn away customers because of certain
characteristics
their race or they're this or they're
that or who they love or what they
believe right around their religion
but this is very awkward because as the
libs are are blurring these two things
and making that claim about the
restaurant
they are simultaneously
turning down conservative customers and
Christian customers turning them away
from their restaurants this just
happened in Richmond the Liberals
violating the ridiculous analogy that
Korean Jean-Pierre is making this was
down at what is it Metzger bar and
Butchery last Wednesday
this is a restaurant that canceled a
dinner reservation made by a Christian
organization because allegedly LGBT
members of their staff said they would
feel uncomfortable or unsafe
we mean they would feel unsafe do you
think the Christians are going to go in
with their violent prayers or something
and no
no you just don't like they the
employees don't like the Christians
and so they say we don't want to serve
them
Christian could never say we don't well
a Christian would not say we don't like
these people and so we're not going to
serve them but if a Christian didn't
want to say that they would not be
allowed to say that but the LGBT
Liberals are allowed to say that to the
Christians apparently uh what did the
restaurant say here's the restaurant
statement Metzger bar and Butchery has
always prided itself on being an
inclusive environment for people to dine
in in eight years of service we have
very rarely refused service to anyone
who wished to dine with us recently we
refuse service to a group that had
booked an event with us after the owners
of Metzger found out it was a group of
donors to a political orientation that
seeks to deprive women and lgbtq persons
of their basic human rights in Virginia
I'm going to translate that for you it's
a group that said that donated to
organizations that say you can't kill
babies and that marriage is between a
man and a woman
it's the most basic ordinary good
statements you're going to make it says
we have always refused service to anyone
for making our staff uncomfortable or
unsafe this was the driving force behind
our decision many of our staff are women
and or members of the LGBT community all
of our staff are people with rights who
deserve dignity in a safe work
environment we respect our staff's
established rights as humans and strive
to create a work environment where they
can do their jobs with dignity comfort
and safety
not only with the libs defend the right
of an LGBT website designer to turn away
Christians who wanted to make them
violate their own views on marriage or
anything else
they are defending the principle that
restaurant owners in Keepers business
owners of any kind have the right to
turn away customers on the very basis of
their beliefs on who they are not for
any service that they're requesting from
the business just because of who the
customers are
as always it should go without saying
the Liberals are doing exactly what they
are falsely accusing their opponents of
doing
it is total projection and it is a
complete double standard but to quote
Adrian vermeul the Harvard law professor
as I often do it is not hypocrisy to
them and pointing out the alleged
hypocrisy is not going to do anything
the Liberals are not asserting a
principle for everybody the Liberals are
asserting two systems of Justice the
Liberals are asserting a caste system
the Liberals are saying we will do what
we want to do and we have the right to
do it because of who we are and who you
people have no rights whatsoever you
Christians and the implication is you
Jews you Muslims you sensible agnostics
but they only go after Christians
because there's political cover to
attack Christians you Christians you
conservatives you have no rights
we you do not have the right to do the
things that we will do ourselves because
you are bad and we are good to quote
Professor vermeul that is not hypocrisy
that is hierarchy
now someday we're all going to have to
answer for all the bad things that we do
and we're going to get up to Saint
Peter's gate and before that happens
you're going to want to have a will
that's why you got to check out epic
will right now go to epicwill.com use
promo code Knowles very very important
to have a wheel a will determines how
your financial assets are dispersed as
well as your personal property it
ensures that your end of life decisions
are honored when you are unable to see
them through for parents a will
determines who will raise your children
should you and your spouse die before
they are of age without a will the state
will make this decision for you if you
were just starting out and you don't
have thousands of dollars to spend on an
attorney but you want to make sure your
savings your belongings and your family
are all protected you have to create
your will at epicwill.com today epic
will bundles your last will living will
Healthcare power of attorney hippo
release and durable Financial power of
attorney it only costs 119 bucks for a
single person to create a will and when
you use promo code Knowles you will save
10 go to epicwill.com use promo code
Knowles to save 10 on Epic those
complete wheel package that is epic
will.com promo code Knowles kwles take
care of your stuff take care of your
family take care of your kids do not let
it go epicworld.com promo code Knowles
speaking of hate speech
is a professor at Rutgers University
who has made the news again I remember
seeing something about her earlier but
this is a tenured professor I believe
or at least 10-year track uh Brittany
Cooper
she's known as Professor Kronk assistant
professor of women's and gender studies
and Africana studies at Rutgers
University so you can tell she's
definitely the creme de La Creme of the
scholars she
she has some thoughts about white people
I think that white people are committed
to being villains in the aggregate right
the real sort of issue here and I you
know I've heard people sort of say it is
one I think that white people viscerally
fear it's not that white people don't
know right what they have done they know
they fear that there is no other way to
be human but the way in which they are
human which is to so you know like you
talk to white people and whenever you
you really want to have a reckoning
about it they say stuff like you know
it's just human nature if y'all had all
of this power you would have done the
same thing right and it's like no that's
what white humans did white human beings
thought there's a world here and we own
it prior to them black and brown people
have been sailing across oceans
interacting with each other for
centuries without total subjugation
domination and colonialism right
it
just as a little historical fact check
here
that that isn't true
they're they're what
you did not have uh black Africans
crossing the Atlantic Ocean to interact
with the Americans that didn't that that
never happened you didn't have Native
Americans crossing the ocean to interact
with Europeans and Africans that that
didn't happen what what she's saying is
white people white people are the
problem they're uniquely bad it isn't
just human nature listen to what she's
saying she's not saying
look this is a fallen world and there
but for the grace of God go I and you
know some people a lot of power can
corrupt people sometimes and no she's
saying it's just it's just white people
white people are bad
black people non-white people in general
are good she goes on about power
I do think that all of us can sort of
agree that our politics that says like
there are superior and inferior human
beings just isn't the way to go and
that's the thing that white people don't
trust us to do because they are so
corrupt you know their thinking is so
morally and spiritually bankrupt about
power that they can't let you know they
fear viscerally existentially letting go
of power because they cannot imagine
that there's another way to be it is
either that you dominate or you are
dominated and isn't it sad that that is
spiritually who they are and that they
can't imagine a sort of more expansive
notion of the world the thing I want to
say to you is we got to take these
[ __ ] out but I know but like we
can't say that right we can't say like I
don't believe in a project of violence I
truly don't because I think in the end
that our souls suffer from that
but you did just say that you you just
said you you accused white people of uh
viewing power dynamics as a relation of
the dominant to the dominated and how
people have to hold on the white people
believe you have to hold on to power
you're not willing to let it go
because these white people believe if
you let it go you know then the people
you give the power to are just going to
want to take you out and also I want to
take these mother refers out so she does
exactly and she says I'm not I can't say
that but you did just say that
and that is obviously
what you believe
that what this professor professor crunk
Brittany Cooper is expressing is a view
of power dynamics
that says we need to take power from
white people and then we need to punish
the white people why
there were people out here making worlds
Africans and Indigenous people being
brilliant and you know libraries and
inventions and you know vibrant Notions
of humanity and cross-cultural exchange
long before white people showed up being
raggedy and violent and terrible and
trying to take everything from everybody
so there there was this history of
The cross-cultural Exchange and
inventions and all this great stuff
before those awful raggedy white people
showed up and and destroyed everything
just as a matter of historical record
there was not there was not Not only was
there not a long history of an invention
in exchange and trade and all in all of
these places
there wasn't even the invention of the
wheel the invention of the wheel did not
occur in the Americas or in Africa they
didn't get the wheel until
exploration until so you might say as
often the the sort of liberals will say
the anti-colonialism anti-western
Liberals will say they'll say well all
these societies were living in this
wonderful Utopia before the damn white
man got there and ruined everything and
it was all basically just Avatar and the
Disney version of Pocahontas so if
you're going to make that claim then you
you actually would want to say yeah
there weren't a lot of inventions there
wasn't a ton of Technology you would
make the liberal claim that it's
actually all of that invention and
consumption and capitalism that destroys
societies you would say no no you keep
your stupid inventions Europeans we hate
we were doing just fine without you
that would be one version of the
argument or the other version of the
argument they could make is no we had
this thriving wonderful Society with all
of these inventions and all of his
technological progress and then you
terrible white people came in and and
screwed it all up but then if you make
that argument then you can't attack
modern capitalism and modern technology
in modern industry as very often that
the people who make these these kind of
arguments do and here Professor Cooper
is trying to make both simultaneously
and it doesn't work it does not hold up
so what is the upshot of all of this I
mean she's she's not making very good
arguments what is the end game here
white folks are not infinite and eternal
right they ain't gonna go on for
infinity and infinity and that's super
important to remember that White's
colonialism and imperialism has a
beginning and in my way of thinking
about the world that means it has an end
and so part of what we are trying to do
is to imagine what it what are the steps
that we must take to get to the other
side of this very inconvenient you know
epaco Interruption of like black and
Indigenous world making I mean does that
give people Comfort on a day to day when
you like just having to deal with white
folks and the track you know the
travesties that they create in the sense
that they want to destroy the planet nah
nah nah of course not but but the end
game is the end of white people and
that's what we all need to hope for and
wait for and pray for is that the white
people will just disappear
genocide isn't what this woman is
calling for why is this clip going
around right now
this clip is not from two days ago this
clip is from last year I believe why is
it making the rounds now
it's more important that it's making the
rounds now than that it made the rounds
a year ago because it's been out there
before and this woman
if she were A different race making
comments about people of another race
would be not only fired from her job of
course she would she would be banned
from everywhere she would be she would
be kicked off of all social media she
would probably be kicked out of her
neighborhood she would probably be
debanked okay she would be removed from
society and she is not
the the reason it matters that that we
see these kinds of videos and see this
kind of commentary is to show you that
very point about hierarchy and hypocrisy
okay the these the the liberal media
want to whip us up into a frenzy about
anything that you possibly could see on
the right meanwhile the things that they
say the things that they do are are so
so much more egregious and and it's why
I can't get worked up it's why I just I
simply to get right back to the first
story of the show I cannot get worked up
about the things Trump does Trump is a
freaking choir boy compared to the libs
the stuff that Trump says that the
tweets the Mean Tweets the things about
people's faces the tax issue that he had
so he's got this minor tax fine I just
it's nothing compared to these people
the fact that I don't know there was
some story about
the Republicans pressuring someone to do
I don't even know remember what was the
first impeachment thing that they tried
it does it doesn't even matter when you
look at the corruption of of the
Democrats when you look at the way that
the Democrats
and potentially the government now it
seems were pressuring social media to
rig their elections right it's just I
don't care because whenever we cover
these stories
the Democrats will say and the libs and
the people on social media Michael you
can't you can't suggest there was a
problem with the election you can't you
can't you have to go out you've got to
constantly attack Republicans whenever
they say anything that is not totally
approved by Twitter and Facebook I don't
I don't want to hear it listen to the
violence the absolutely vile
rhetoric coming out of this woman's
mouth
fact that no one has cared it's been out
there for a year that that tells you
more than anything that she or any
Republican has to say speaking of ending
things
there is some good news coming out of
Capitol Hill House Democrats are siding
with the GOP
against the president against Joe Biden
on the military vaccine mandate I love
this this is a great story as Democrats
are poised to defy Biden by joining the
House Republicans to jettison the
requirement for service members to get
the covet backs according to a new
report
great news
what about the the military members
who were booted out for not taking the
fauciatchi what about them
3 400 service members
have been discharged from the military
for refusing the coveted vaccine what
about them
are they going to get their jobs back
are they going to be given back pay are
they what's going to happen to those
guys
that's the next question
we know this is a winning issue for
Republicans that military vaccine
mandate is so deeply unpopular the house
Democrats have to side with the
Republicans against Joe Biden to repeal
it that's how deeply unpopular it is and
why are they doing that is because they
have integrity is it because they've got
principles because if they had a change
of heart no no what are you talking
about it's because they're up for
election every two years and Joe Biden
very possibly will not run for
re-election again and is is insulated
from those political forces now we've
got to push this further we should not
be fighting the
modest political Battle of repealing
this vaccine mandate sure get that done
but you got to take a lesson from people
like Trump you've actually got to take a
lesson from people with the audacity of
that professor at Rutgers okay make
Bolder demands
Donald Trump always talks past the sale
this is one of the great observations of
Scott Adams so he says look there was
this fraud at Twitter so now we've got
two options either you immediately
reinstate me as president or we hold a
snap election
as though there were no other option
there that's that's the way that Trump
talks that's what he does this woman she
says I don't like white people so what
are we going to do we're going to
uh pray for their genocide not just
we're going to change the law to make it
tougher for white people we're going to
genocide the white people okay that's
not advocating that obviously not even
close uh but it shows you
fortune favors the Bold okay the libs
are extremely bold the libs right now
are making arguments that a Christian
website designer doesn't have the right
not to participate in a gay marriage but
also that restaurants have the right to
turn away Christians because allegedly
an LGBT waiter just
doesn't like Christians and so that's
that's enough reason to turn them away
and to refuse them public accommodation
okay they're making these arguments with
a straight face and and what are we
doing we're saying oh excuse me would
you think maybe would it be all right if
maybe we just get rid of the military
vaccine mandate please give me a break
come on come on guys we talk about
gender identity these days how about we
grow some of those anatomical features
that we always keep talking about and go
a little bit further and get a little
bit Bolder Christmas Is Almost Here
everybody many of you are already daily
wire Plus members and you get to enjoy
the great content that we've released
this year such as what is a woman the
greatest lie ever sold if you have not
been able to enjoy it because you're not
a member then take advantage of our 30
Christmas sale this also applies to gift
memberships that do not miss this
opportunity to get everyone on your list
an annual gift membership from daily
wire plus with code holiday at checkout
since joining daily wire plus Jordan
Peterson has ramped up his already busy
schedule we've been reaping the rewards
earlier this fall Jordan went to
Washington DC to film a beautiful and
engaging documentary on the Museum of
the Bible
it's called logos and literacy in it
Jordan meets with historians theologians
and philosophers to discuss the history
of the Bible and its influence on the
world Jordan sent us a note to say how
happy he was with the way that it turned
out he actually watched it twice no
doubt you will want to do the same but
the only way you can is if you are a
daily wire plus member so sign up to
that use code holiday at checkout to get
30 off your near daily wire addual
membership at dailywire.com that's
dailywire.com Knowles today
the Liberals are unpopular
the things that the Liberals have done
are very unpopular destroy the economy
their immigration policies their foreign
policy their vaccine policies they're
very unpopular so then you've got to ask
yourself why do we keep losing
why did Herschel Walker lose last night
why did Kerry Lake lose an Arizona why
did Blake Masters lose in Arizona
why did we lose the senate race why
you're going to have people who are in
the more moderate wing of the party
they're going to blame Donald Trump you
can have people who are more in the
conservative wing of the party blame the
establishment whatever
I don't really care who you blame
but somebody has to take responsibility
we can't just keep going on and on and
on like this
so you're seeing this fight play out
at the level of the RNC
there is a big fight for the leadership
of the Republican National Committee
right now the current chairman is Ronald
McDaniel uh conservative attorney
harmeet Dillon said that she is going to
challenge Rana for the chairmanship uh
there's actually another candidate
Mercedes schlapp
is former Trump White House official
wife of Matt schlapp who's the the head
of the American conservative Union she
has also signaled that she might run for
the position I'm not sure that she's
actually announced yet
either way I know all of these women I
like all of these women
I was struck
again as we talk about
gender Dynamics so much these days
does no man want to run the RNC how come
it's only women who are saying aren't we
the traditional party guys don't isn't
it the old you know
get those Gary Cooper types out there
the strong and Silent type and go out
there and what happened to I don't know
no men want to run the RNC apparently
but all these women they're great I like
them all I'm not not making an
endorsement we had Harmony Dylan on our
election coverage last month
I like all of them
we need
accountability though okay so
I don't know who's going to take the
fall for what happened in the midterms
it could be Rana because she's running
the RNC it could be Mitch McConnell
because he's the Republican leader in
the Senate it could be Kevin McCarthy
he's the Republican leader in the house
it could be Donald Trump he played a big
role it could I don't I don't know who
it's going to be
what I don't want is to just keep doing
the same thing over and over and over
and expecting different results and you
might say well Michael the Republicans
didn't do as well because of voter fraud
and because of the rigged elections
is the way that the Democrats changed
all the rules to benefit them yeah okay
that's fine or because the Democrats are
doing ballot harvesting or because the
Democrats are smarter at the balance and
yeah sure I'm sure it's all of those
things well what are we going to do
about it
why doesn't the RNC have a strategy for
ballot harvesting why doesn't the RNC
have a strategy to get rid of ballot
harvesting in the states why doesn't the
RNC have a strategy for early voting why
doesn't the RNC have a strategy to get
rid of early voting I just I just need
something okay
is it it's not enough to just whine and
complain and say oh well you know the
dem's outfoxed us we're hiring you to
Outfox them so out Fox them come on I
remember in the early days of this
website
daily wire every few months Facebook
would change its algorithm and we were
very very reliant on Facebook
for the the algorithm okay so we were
reliant on them to give us our views we
were relying on them to make a lot of
our money and so what would we what
would we do when they change the
algorithm our website traffic would go
down and we would say oh well that's the
algorithm well no you can't you can't
just throw your hands up in the air
because then you don't have a website
anymore okay
you have to adapt you have to win I
don't want any more freaking excuses
from the Republican Party figure it out
lawlessness is a huge problem here okay
look at look at the Democrats they don't
feel they have to be accountable at all
Joe Biden was just asked what he is
doing about the Border
here's Biden's answer
because they're more important thing
going on they're going to invest
billions of dollars in a new Enterprise
yeah we got bigger problems
this is a major problem according to
public opinion polls if you look at
public opinion polls right now the the
issue of immigration is important to
everybody not just Republicans Democrats
too the majority of Americans want to
drastically reduce all immigration to
the United States
but Mr President you're flooding the
country with two million illegals every
single year yeah we got bigger problems
whatever moving what are you going to do
to me
what are you going
to do to me
when you're seeing this lawlessness
trickle down everywhere look right now
in North Philly
is a gas station owner who has just
hired private security
to ensure that his customers can fill up
their tanks
and when I say private security by the
way
I'm not talking about a mall cop with a
billy club I'm talking about guys who
are clad out in Black
with a very impressive black rifles
masks covering their face hoodies up
armor on
because in a major American city the
city
where we had the Continental Congress
okay the city with the Liberty Bell
people cannot fill up their gas tanks
without fear of being shot
this is a breakdown of
the political order
and you're going to see more of it
you're going to see more and more I hate
to give the Libertarians any credit here
but increasingly you are going to see
more and more the
wealthy hiring their own security
what did you think was going to happen
the Democrats called for defunding the
police and abolishing the police for two
years well they did that in many places
and then what happens you need cops you
need security and so people are going to
start hiring it themselves and this is
the acceleration of a trend that has
been really tough in the United States
and it's not only the left's fault
the the right has actually played a role
in this for the last half century you
have seen the privatization
of our country
and I know the Republicans from many
years at least talked about how great
privatization is we need to privatize
everything the government's always bad
well at a certain point then
you end up in a situation where the
people who control your political order
are basically completely unaccountable
you privatize the Public Square okay now
Facebook Google and Twitter control the
Public Square which means they control
the American political order and until
Elon Musk bought it they all hated us
and they could rig elections
if you you if you privatize your whole
country away
you're you're yes you've reduced the
risk of big government sometimes but now
you're just beholden to corporations and
if my rights and way of life are being
taken away by some awful corporation
that hates me I don't feel any better
than if the government were taking my
rights and my way of life away
Democrats privatized the social sector
Republicans privatized the economy and
now we've got private police forces
that's the best we can do because we
don't even have a police force anymore
not good
at all and you've got Joe Biden saying
oh yeah our borders that's not important
that's not an important thing speaking
of unimportant things there is a trailer
out
to a show
that I know that they're going to make
me watch I know that daily wire is going
to force me to watch this
and that fills me with Dread
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
[Music]
[Applause]
and then
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about hatred
it's about race it's a dirty game
and suffering of women marrying into
this institution this feeling frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want history to
repeat itself
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
I love that it ends on that
contradiction just to show you how
stupid this whole thing is
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth well you just
said no one knows the full truth man you
just this is not giving me confidence
and there's actually some deception in
that trailer too there's a picture of
the the paparazzi taking photographs of
of Meghan Markle it would seem that's
the implication it's not it was a photo
taken long before Meghan Markle ever
entered into the picture
it may have been a photo from a sporting
event but it was it was so even just
that
shows you how deceptive this is but no
one's buying this at all right no one's
buying that nobody knows the trouble
that Harry and Megan have seen and it's
not as though Meghan Markle had were
just drawn into the royal family
accidentally you know she met a guy at a
bar and then she finds out after she
accepts this wedding proposal oh my gosh
he's a prince no you're just my luck I
thought I met a nice accountant who
would have a private life in the suburbs
it turns out my his name's Harry I don't
know if you know he's got red hair turns
out he's a prince can you imagine
ah just my luck
Meghan Markle who obviously went to
England to go print shopping with the
goal of marrying into this family but
why did she want to leave then
because all she wanted was the perks of
the family and she didn't realize that
the family actually serves that the
point of the monarchy is not is not what
the libs and the Communists would have
you believe which is just to drink
champagne and enjoy all this luxury the
point of the monarchy is actually to
suppress your personality suppress your
personal desires and just serve the
country you are not when you are The
Sovereign you are not really permitted
to be an individual
you were supposed to suppress all of
that that's what the crown does that's
what the vestments do that's why this is
why priests put on investments at church
on Sunday and this is this is why the
royalty do that as well it's not to make
themselves look like a rock star or
something quite the opposite it's to
cover up their personality and and to to
find themselves subsumed within the
institution as The Sovereign they don't
want to do that
this is another it actually ties in
with what we we've been talking about
about privatization
right it ties in with this idea that
neither the left nor the right want to
serve their country anymore that what
John F Kennedy said when he said ask not
what your country could do for you but
what you can do for your country that is
now a meaningless statement to both the
left and the right
because the left looks at it they say I
hate my country my country is an evil
white supremacist bigoted terrible it's
the worst place in the world I want to
burn it down and then the right says
what do I care about my country my
country is with that government I hate
the government the common good I don't
know what the common good means and I'm
gonna certain no I'm not I'm going to go
down to Wall Street and make a lot of
money greed is good baby let's boost up
that GDP let's Outsource some jobs let's
open up the borders and let's just lower
wages and let's have ruthless
competition yeah baby and so it's that's
what you've got and you've gotten two
sides of the same coin from both the
left and the right
redounding uh to to damage to the
country the entire time and it was a
really dumb bet for the right to make
because now all that privatization we
gave up All That Power from our
political order and now it's being
wielded by people who hate our guts not
a good that was a Faustian bargain if
you ask me
now you know it's woke Wednesday
we have a great great presentation today
to educate all of us to open up our
minds
from Love Don't Judge okay I'm gonna I
want you to have your Consciousness
elevated with me we're going to reserve
our judgment we're going to see how long
we can reserve our judgment while
watching this the rest of the show
continues now if you're not the member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]